Hello.
We are now live.
Outstanding.
Yeah. Thank you for joining me. It's such
short notice. I literally messaged you, like,
three minutes ago.
Probably less than that. I had just finished
my lunch and sat back down at my
desk when I got your message, and I
was like, yeah. Let's do this.
Yeah. This would be fun. So
we're gonna take a look at QuestDB today,
which is a time series database that you
joined recently. Do you wanna just
give us a quick thirty second pitch?
Sure. QuestDB
is
the
we're
we're the fastest open source time series database
out there right now.
It is blindingly fast,
written from scratch,
SQL based time series database.
So if you know SQL,
you're already
mostly there.
And it's really small, actually. It's even embeddable.
It's I think the entire download for it
is, like,
three megs
as long as you use if you're using
your own JVM. If you download it with
a j if you if you're using an
embedded JVM, it's a little more because you
gotta have the JVM, but it's really quite
small. Yeah.
Alright. Cool.
Well, I know SQL, SQL. So in theory,
I should get on to staying here. Right?
In theory, yes.
Alright. Let me bring up my screen then.
I think
there we go. So this is just the
the website.
So
fast equal series time series. I got some
docker commands, which is great. But recently, there
was the ability to deploy this to Kubernetes.
I wonder who did that for us.
Which I did out of curiosity more than
anything because I was like, hey. Let's let's
play with this. And
when I built the helm chart to deploy
it to Kubernetes,
you know, I I kinda looked at the
UI and kicked it around a little bit,
but I'm not really given it some proper
attention that it's a does it that it
deserves yet. And that's what I wanna do
just now. So
the chart is open source, of course, and
it is here.
So
let's just have a quick look.
I'm just gonna copy this entire values file.
I'm gonna tweak it. If it's ever I
don't know what it is. I'm just gonna
throw questions at you.
K. I will try and get this deployed
pretty quickly.
So
oh, I already cleaned up the chart. Oh,
I'm one step ahead of myself. Okay.
So that's all pretty self explanatory.
The tag there says 501. Did I make
that up, or it's on version five?
No. And I think we're you probably wanna
move it to 502.
K.
We don't wanna do any tweaking here.
Does the worker can't matter? What are these
JVM options?
No.
Those are not
JVM options that I know of. You can
use it. Leave that at two. It should
be fine. Yeah.
Persistence. Alright. So I'm just going to apply
this straight up. Let's let's just see what
happens. Yeah. Let's see what happens.
Around the house, it can happen. Right?
Well, manager, I'll fix that. It's because I've
got a very current version of helm. So
we're gonna do upgrade.
Install.
I'm
gonna have to fix that then.
Oh, it's a problem on a livestream. Right?
Oh, yeah.
So it's just complaining that we want a
metadata tag here.
I don't remember who's gonna actuate.
As my
well, the CEO of a company I used
to work for used to say, you know,
if if the demo works every time it's
a product, ship it.
Alright. Let's see. I have this header. Stack
Overflow generate.
I guess we can do that in cockpit,
can't we?
Put the temp directory.
Run this.
I need a name.
Oh, that's not the right command at all.
Be this is why it should never trust
that workflow.
So
just grab one of these charts, see what
I'm missing.
Nothing.
Maybe I'm just reading the error too quickly
for no one. Mhmm. Okay. Chart dot metadata
is required.
Found that for this chart then.
Well, that's not been updated in a while.
Let's pick a new one.
Maybe I'll learn something about Kubernetes watching you
do this. Maybe I'll actually learn how to
work myself.
Okay. Home container sources keyword. It's automatic data
at once.
Oh,
I'm being really, really silly right now.
Let's just Google the error. This is how
I spend most of my days anyway.
Googling error messages. Absolutely.
It's been one of those weeks where I
feel like I think I actually tweak it.
I'm just saying I spent 50% of my
time banging my head off the wall and
50% of my time asking questions. It's just
definitely one of those weeks.
And,
eventually, you get pretty good at skimming this
stuff.
How did anybody write anything before there was
Stack Overflow?
I don't know. Chart metadata.
I haven't seen a definitive answer into what
causes this.
Ah, have the wrong directory.
See? There we go. I'm not even in
the chart directory.
That's
Oh, well, that could be a problem.
Hey. While you're typing, I can show you
this little thing I built this week. Can
you see this?
Yes.
I have the graph on it. Yep.
Look how small it is.
Uh-huh. It's What's what's what's going on there?
It's particulate matter. It's a three micron particulate
matter
and sending it to QuestDB.
Ah, cool.
Okay. So we're past the first hurdle. It
turns out if you want to deploy a
Helm chart, then you have to tell it
where the Helm chart is. Like, go figure.
So Oh, yeah. Well, who would've guessed that?
It it's a Friday, like, ten to six
in the evening, so I'm gonna freak out
myself for that. Anyway,
we're gonna run, take it pods,
and we see that we have one QuestDB
running.
Awesome. So it does expose a UI. Right?
It does. 9,000.
Nine thousand.
I'm just gonna port forward to it, and
then we'll see what we're dealing with here.
So QuestDB
9,000,
and we can avoid those crappy errors I
was doing.
This is it. Here it is.
So do I get any metrics,
like, internal metrics, or am I gonna have
to start writing something to this?
That looks like internal metrics.
So just hit run. Yeah. You got internal
metrics.
Okay. I this is the telemetry stuff is
new, and I haven't looked at it yet.
So I don't know what you're what exactly
you're gonna be getting. If you wanna send
data to it, you're gonna have to expose
port 9,009.
That's not on the chart.
So are we messing up port from this?
The nine nine thousand nine is both the
TCP and the UDP port for influx line
protocol.
Oh, that has its own port. Right? At
least it can start to get a pill
request this evening then. So
we'll call this influx to be
in our port.
and then protocol
I
don't know if you can add that twice.
Because unless I can't listen on both. Does
it? It will actually it well, I don't
know. On my machine, it will listen on
both ports as long as one of them
as long as they're different.
I know it works on my machine, so
I guess we should ship my machine.
Oh, it seems good. I didn't know you
could do that. See? I'm learning too. Alright.
But we described this.
We go to
send all these ports.
What's port? Alright.
Okay. Yeah. It's just taking the TCP, and
that's fine by me, though. So Yeah. That's
yeah.
Alright.
Calamity data is no fun. Let's
let's get something else in here. The torn.
Do we wanna stick in something big, or
do we wanna just kick the tires a
little bit? You can just if you just
turn on Telegraph,
you know, it automatically starts collecting just a
ton of stuff. Right?
Yeah. You're right. I'll probably do it inside
the
container, though.
I'll deploy it via helm,
or should I just run one locally? I
even have Totally up to you.
I see how it's for this. We can
always just do that.
And I'll just quickly put together a telegraph
configs in.
So
agent
interval
and
input CPU.
Then
disk.
Let's take a look at that. And I'm
using the end fuck TV output?
No. Actually, you're doing the
output. I believe it's the
socket. Let me look.
Oh, I don't yeah. I'm gonna have to
I'm sorry. I can fill up the docs
here. Kinda gonna get it up.
But I just need to send lane protocol
on a TCP socket. Right? That that's it.
So
I can work that out.
Copy that.
Uh-huh.
Copy
that.
So we wanna write to TTP
9009.
Yep. Because this is Kubernetes, we're gonna take
advantage of their services,
which means their QuestDB is available,
and we'll we need to expose the extra
port for that sign. And I'll push these
changes up as a PR to that chart
for other Okay. So
which means we're just looking for
QuestDB
909,
and I'll probably need to set the data
format.
Yep.
Anything else? That's it.
Okay. In fact, I installed that's for Bruce,
so we're not using that. So
we'll do that there.
Alright. Let's see what happens if I run
telegraph,
config
port forward dot extra port.
So, like, QuestDB
9,009.
Right. So
Telegraph isn't mourning yet, so that's maybe a
good sign.
That's a good sign if Telegraph's not either
mourning or crashing.
So just hit hit the
I need my second port forward to the
web interface.
Oh, yeah.
Well, look at that.
Alright. So what what's the table in QuestDB?
Is that a measurement and then flux?
Basically, yeah. Basically, yeah.
I can just run this.
Oh, there we go. And there we go.
Cool.
Alright.
Now here here's something that that I didn't
know when I did this the first time
was that
if you
actually create the table first and designate a
time a time stamp
column,
then
some of this Telegraph stuff doesn't work as
well because
it a Telegraph occasionally tries to do an
out of order insert.
Oh. And if you have a designated
time stamp column,
then you can't do right now, you can't
do out of order inserts.
Okay.
Alright. I'll try not to do that. Well
yeah.
But we're fixing that. Actually,
Vlad's been
been
working on out of order inserts
lately, and he hopes to have that done
pretty quickly. We also are hoping that our
Grafana plug in will be ready pretty quickly.
Okay. The copywriting here says twenty fourteen to
2020.
Yep. So QuestDB has been around a while?
Absolutely.
Yeah. Seven years, actually. Was it always open
source, or is that something that happened recently?
I'm not quite sure when. I think it
was mostly open source. Vlad basically started writing
this in his spare time.
And he wrote it and he basically wrote
it,
and then he was like, oh, well, you
know, what I did was shit. So he
threw the whole thing away and started over
again and rewrote the whole thing.
And and
because he was trying to get his basically,
the performance as close to the hardware as
possible.
Right?
Okay.
So
alright. Teach me then. How do I do
some time series stuff? How can I calculate
how can I just pull out a single
field? We set this as SQL. Right? Can
I just select?
Yep.
And the
usage idle
from CPU?
Yep.
Alright. Yep.
Boom.
Okay.
If you wanna see the time stamp, then
select
CPU idle and time stamp. Right? So
Okay.
So well, I'm gonna need the CPU.
I want usage idle and then change that.
I'll just comment that back out. I like
that I can just command
and
slash the comments.
Oh, let's get you to Yeah.
Nero did a really nice job on the
editor for the for this.
Yeah. Good.
Okay. Let's try something else then. So So
if you click on that down there that
says chart.
Uh-huh.
So
for labels,
under under that labels pull down, choose time
stamp and
remove time stamp from the series
there and now hit draw.
Move.
It's a bar chart. Change it to a
line chart and redraw it.
Okay.
So this is
alright. Okay. I got it. So
So it may be that you're pulling
go back to your your your grid view,
the table and see because says there's eight
CPUs. No. 15 CPUs. That so that's why
it looks like that. Yeah. Okay. So can
I
verify
Duo Duo where CPU zero where
CPU e
equals CPU zero?
What?
Single quote.
Yeah.
So now you only have CPU zero.
Here you go.
Okay.
That's
what I would expect. Right? Value change over
time. That's a little more reasonable. You what
you were seeing was eight CPUs all drawn
in the right in the same column.
Alright. So how do I how do I
translate the mean event of all my CPUs?
I do let's see.
Take that off. Can I just do mean?
Yep.
Oh, nope.
Not bad.
So how Okay. How how does this Yeah.
Try lowercase.
I think that red squiggle means bad, though.
Right? Yeah.
The red squiggle's bad.
See, I know that. I get that my
code all the Maybe you can do average.
Yeah. Average will work. Yep.
That's just a b t. Yep. There we
go. Okay.
Let's do that.
And that's the only one that'll give me
CP.
But you're in you're in chart mode, so
go back to
grid. There you go.
It's because I took off the
CPU
and times no. Time stuff is still there.
So
You can also do
right. You wanna take out yeah. There you
go. Here's your average.
Okay. So how if I had to move
the where, that will get me the average
of all GPUs?
Yeah. You don't wanna get one series or
would I get 16 series? I don't know.
You don't even need this.
Alright. Okay. So
I've got the average pair of CDs. I
guess that yeah. That feels natural. That's what
I would expect.
I'm trying to work out. What what would
I do if I wanted to group all
of those together and calculate the average then?
Just group
by
or would that group by the value of
the CPU?
So,
basically, our group by is is
no op because it it automatically
groups.
Okay.
So let's see.
If I take group,
we get this lovely documentation page. That's pretty
nice. Okay.
I can group by sensor ID.
I can do multiple fields
on the group by. Okay.
Nice.
And I think you have this for oh,
yeah. All the functions are here. Yeah. We
got all the all the support functions there.
Oh, show statement.
I can introspect the database. Let's have a
look. That's how you get the that's how
the tables are are
in that side.
You'll notice that that looks exactly like your
little sidebar there.
It does. That's how we get that. Yeah.
Actual columns
from
desk.
Ah, cool. Okay.
I like playing with new tools.
What's that? I like playing with new things.
I can just,
you know, that little bit of joy you
get when you work at something else or
learn something. Yep. So
So what you'll notice there is that we
have we're using symbol and not string.
And what does that mean?
So here's the here's the thing.
The way that
one of the way and I just had
the a like, an hour long talk with
Vlad. I'm in the process of of writing
this up as a blog post because it's
super interesting how he did this.
Everything is stored
as
eight bytes.
Right? So everything lines up on eight byte
columns.
Right?
So that it's really, really fast because we
know exactly where everything starts and stops. Right?
But strings
are weird because they can be any length.
So you can't store a string in exactly
eight bytes unless you're only gonna allow people
to store eight bytes worth of string data,
which is kind of limiting.
So so
what it does is we store it as
what's called a symbol.
And what it what it actually does is
it puts the the string data in a
different table,
and it stores the basically, a pointer to
that string
in in the
eight byte
column.
So it keeps everything lined up by eight
bytes, but now we know exactly where to
go to get the value.
Right?
Okay.
And it's making it up a lot.
Right.
Alright. That makes sense. I got it. I
got it. I got there. Just to give
back time. So one of the other things
that we talked about yesterday
I talked about yesterday with
Vlad and Patrick, one of the other engineers,
is
what they had been doing was,
you know
basically, we're we're memory mapping everything. Right?
Okay.
And what they had been doing was creating
pages in memory map of of memory map.
And then when you get to, you know,
when you get to the end of a
page, well, they create another page,
and there were all these, like, if
then else is to figure out which page
stuff was on and where stuff went on
page breaks.
And what they did
just, like, a week or two ago was
they
they instead of having multiple pages, they just
decided to make one ginormous
page. Right?
Two to the sixty fourth because it's a
64 bit database.
One page that's huge.
And then they don't have to try to
decide what page they have to look in
because it's all in one page.
And they don't have to allocate the whole
thing. They can just
when it gets full, they just, you know,
grow the same page figures. They don't have
to worry about where the page boundary is.
There's no more page boundaries.
And it turns out that if, you know,
all that branching around, if this is in
a page or if it's in the next
page and going from page to page was
really slowing things down, they got something like
a 60%
speed bump
by
doing this
this page thing, and they're doing something that
I'm I'm kind of a may I asked
Vlad yesterday. He's like, why didn't anybody else
think of this? Because a lot of other
databases
basically try to outsmart the kernel
and do a lot of this stuff,
you know,
themselves.
They take the job away from the kernel
and try to outsmart the colonel. But,
really, this is the colonel's job, right, is
to know exactly where everything is in memory
and on disk and how to get there
fast.
And so why not just let the colonel
do its job and not try to, you
know,
take a bit of memory from the kernel
and map it sideways into my database, and
then I have to reference that, which references
into the kernel, which gets the memory address.
Right? It adds another layer of indirection.
And so if they're not doing that, they're
basically just letting the kernel do its job
and not trying to be smarter than the
kernel, which they're not gonna be. Right? You're
basically not gonna be smarter than the kernel.
Okay. I think that's a very good take
home lesson. Don't try to be smarter than
the kernel.
So you cannot touch the performance with that.
Like, if I remember right, was it a
month ago? You you made, like, a is
it was a billion
points database public? I can't remember the details.
Do you wanna Yeah. You can go you
can actually go there right now. It's still
live.
What's the URL?
Try.questdp.i0port9thousand.
This is just a public QuestDB. And how
big is the dataset?
1,600,000,000
rows. If you just do click on if
if you just run trips.
Run that.
So you got 1,600,000,000
rows in what you get? Three milliseconds?
Execute
three milliseconds.
Network 20 so, yeah, tool 32. It's pretty
fast.
Three milliseconds to go get 1,600,000,000
rows, and there's some sample queries up under
there under example queries.
Ah, okay. So you can actually do an
average overall 1,600,000,000
rows,
like, the average distance.
Right? Well, let's do that average fare keyed
by passenger
cab. Right. So
alright. Go.
So I guess that's then works out how
many people that are in each of the
cab rates and then parts of average fare
is basically trying to figure out how zero
people in a cab cost average $10, but
I'm I'm you know? And what was the
speed of execution of that?
So that was
execute four hundred and forty nine milliseconds.
Right.
And that's not a that's not a simple
query. Right?
No. It's not. Definitely not.
Cool. So then But again, that's over 1,600,000,000
rows.
Let's see what else we've got. So is
there a command line interface, or do you
have to use the web interface?
Right. Well so you can
basically do a command line interface, but it's
it's
via it's basically you're running it via curl.
Right?
Alright. We don't have a straight command line
interface.
And what's
okay. Let's just I'm just gonna do this,
actually, because I wanna see what the edit
is. I'll do my local one rather than
Oh, so
it actually
there's two endpoints
for
if you
We can just scale it from here. Right?
There we go.
Yeah. And it's so it's either depending on
which endpoint, it's either returning a CSV or
it's returning a JSON.
So if I see
it's not normally a copy of curl.
What's here?
No.
Oh, there we go.
So let's pop over here. I'll just grab
a new tab, temp directory.
So
but it has the exact end point. It's
past let a bit of math here, columns.
Oh, no. Wait. That's just the query. So
show okay. Yeah.
So I believe I can't remember. There's there's
an exact endpoint, and then there's a an
EXP endpoint. And and one of them returns
CSV,
and one of them returns
JSON. It looks like is that one returning
JSON? Yes.
Yeah. That's it. We can put it through
Jake here.
What am I doing? And and and and
and
there
we go.
Yeah. Nice.
I like it when things return JSON. It
means I can What's that? I like it
when things return JSON because it just means
it's so easy to script against that. It's
so easy to consume it and use it
and, you know, forward onto other functions. Yeah.
It's really easy to deal with. And and
the the other endpoint will give you CSV
if that's what you want.
Which endpoint is that?
Now you're asking hard questions.
That's okay. It's not it's not important.
I got what I needed. I see some
JSON, and I executed the query on the
command line. So that's that's progress for me.
Alright.
What what should I be aware of? Like,
before we wrap up then, like,
what what have I not asked? What have
I not covered? What what do I need
to know about QuestDB?
In terms of, like, things to avoid or
things to do? Or Oh, no. Just even
superficially.
Like, is there anything that I've not touched
here that's really cool? I mean, I've just
kind of thrown a little bit of data
testing.
Yeah. I mean so I've got a version
running here on my laptop that I've been
sending
IoT data to, and it's got sort of,
like, 2,300,000
data points in it right now.
And it's still,
you know, I'm I'm getting,
you know, millisecond level responses
to queries on the data.
So it's
it's
one of the things that I really like
about it is that it's really small and
it's really fast. So it it's it's got
both small and fast.
And it's as you see, it's well, I
mean, I don't know about Kubernetes,
but it's super easy to deploy because you
basically just start the binary and it runs.
Right?
Yeah. The Kubernetes deployment was you know, it's
pretty standard. I think just I wasn't aware
of the Netflix DB protocol.
I had to go and add a few
things, but
Right. Well, that's to get
sorry. We've had influx DB line protocol for
UDP
for quite some time,
but we just added the TCP
version of it, which actually has made a
bunch of the stuff that I do for
IoT really a lot easier because
I don't have to
with UDP, I basically had to keep opening
and closing the the connection because you never
know.
And with the TCP one, I can basically
open a connection and it'll stay open for
literally days and just I I just write
data to it. Right?
Ah,
that's pretty cool. So I I write data
to it every second, and it just takes,
you know, takes tons and tons of data.
Okay.
Yeah. It definitely sounds interesting. I mean, when
you say that it's small and fast, like,
right away, I'm like, but it's the JVM.
And this is it doesn't compute to me,
but I can see that it's, you know,
small and fast. It's just Yeah. Not something
that I'm used to. And I as I
guess I'm not that
I haven't played with the GVM a lot
over the last even probably ten years. So
I'm not sure it has changed for the
better drastically.
So I you know, look, I started with
with Java in 1995
before it was called Java. So
I I'm well aware of the it's interpreted
so it's slow. Right?
But starting
really in the sort of the the
early two thousands maybe
with some of the just in time compiling.
And then certainly by the mid two thousands,
you were getting near native speed out of
the JVM.
Right?
I worked on a a very large storage
project at some labs, and they wrote the
whole thing in Java. And they were actually
getting better performance out of Java than they
were out of the stuff that they'd written
in c,
Right?
Which
shocked me. I didn't think that that was
possible.
And one of the things that Vlad has
done here is that one of the things
that gets you with the JVM is garbage
collection. Right?
Because you never know when the JVM is
gonna say, you know, hold on a second.
I gotta collect garbage, and it's gonna go
away while it collects garbage. This
is zero garbage collection.
So the JVM never stops to collect garbage
because it generates zero garbage.
Wow.
Yeah. C plus plus and zero garbage collection
Java. Yep.
Tiny memory footprint, vectorized QD execution.
I don't really know what that means, but
it sounds really impressive.
Well, basically, the queries are
are running parallel.
Right?
Ah, got it. Okay. Cool.
Oh, I guess that that's nicely with the
70 then, the fact that you can execute
is it single
instruction multiple data. Right? So you're executing the
same thing across data and different points of
memory. Yes. I think that's how it works.
Yeah.
And and that's one of the reasons that
some of it is written in c plus
plus and and is that it's
the performance of it is very, very, very
closely tied to the performance of the hardware.
Right?
So the faster
it's always true that the faster your hardware,
the faster your whatever it is is gonna
run.
But this is really, really close to, you
know, sort of optimal
hardware performance
because of how closely aligned it is to
memory memory
boundaries
and and such. So that it gets just
maximum performance
out of it.
Very cool.
I'm just looking at these
sample queries,
I guess. So this syntax here, that's that's
obviously some sort of magic string. So it's
saying where time stamp is what? Greater than
the fourteenth spot.
Minus two days.
So does that mean it goes from the
fourteenth to the sixteenth or the twelfth to
the fourteenth? It goes to the twelfth to
the fourteenth.
Nice syntax.
I guess the sample by, is this for
doing windowing?
Yep.
Nice.
Latest, that is that just getting me one
value?
Yeah. From that set from that one from
that one
Latest.
Right.
K.
Wait. That's a short call.
Oops.
Let's do something actually useful. So so that
Yeah. Let's your columns isn't useful,
isn't it?
Or the usage angle from
CPU.
Ah, sure. Okay.
If I kept the CPU, then I guess
that would probably make more sense. But
the syntax is
what's this last one?
As of join whether
So that will join
the two things together. It's basically a a
it's a kind of join, and I don't
ask me about
as of joins because I'm I'm terrible at
this. My
my SQL is is old and rusty, and
it's just getting back up to speed.
But I believe that you can run that
query.
Oh, no. Send it's sensors.
There is a in the
in the
try demo, I believe there is one that's
an as of join.
I mean, I'm gonna try and just do
it first. Out of complete curiosity. It's if
I do it as of join, can I
bring in
this?
Or does it need some sort of joining
field?
Ambiguous column name.
Now I'm assuming that's because the timestamp exists
some
no. Both?
Let me check. So CPU
Go look at the
at the QuestDB demo and see if we
can find an as of join in there.
Host.
I know it's host. I wanna I wanna
hack it before I go look up the
demo. Okay.
So how do I disambiguate then? Let's see.
That doesn't have any
I don't even want a horse.
Ah, tracks.
Alright. Let's go look it up.
So
and there's a mess up there. So we're
saying select all of each oh, you could
do math inside the select. Cool.
From trips as of joint gas prices.
What's that doing?
Oh, I broke it.
Just go reselect the the query and rerun
it.
I'm
sure I just typed something by mistake and
broke it. So this is grabbing
cab type,
which I guess is coming from the trip.
I
don't know. And then adding on the gas
price.
Yep.
Okay.
And it's joining and it and it's basically
I think it's joining them on
on the
pickup date and time.
Yeah.
Alright.
So
I won't put you on the spot because
I know
it's a tough question, but I wonder how
I can disambiguate that host field so that
I can do that join.
What's the what's the error? I can barely
I can't really see the error it's giving
you when you try to run that query.
Oh, sorry.
So it says ambiguous column name, and that's
because both the CPU I'm I'm assuming you
can correct me if I'm wrong. The CPU
and the disk tables both have a host
column.
Maybe that's just It oh, no. It looks
like it's complaining about the time stamp.
Oh.
That's the one that's under that that's Oh.
Square bit.
So if I just take that off?
And then it said I have no time
stamp. Right.
No. Put the put the time stamp in
the ASF join.
Like, comma, time stamp? Or Yep.
Nope. I didn't didn't leave that.
Let's try the documentation.
I just spent thirty seconds on this, and
then we'll just wrap up. I don't wanna
I I actually have twenty minutes, and we're
currently at forty two minutes into this.
So
right as of join.
Yeah. It's maybe too much for me to
try and consume here in that short.
I will play with that later, I think.
Okay.
Anyway, that seems cool. I like it. So
before we finish then, like, does QuestDB
have
cardinality problems?
No.
That was the fastest no I think I've
ever heard. So
yeah. You mean I didn't answer with it
depends? No. Because it's a it's a columnar
data store. Right?
So one of the problems with with cardinality
that you ran into with, say, in FlexDB
was that it basically created a series
for each
tag and datasets.
Right?
Mhmm. That's correct. And so that's where you've
got your cardinality was the number of tags
and the and the number of values. Right?
That's the sort of the the the easy
calculation of of cardinality is you multiply your
tag set by your value set, and that's
your cardinality. Right?
Right. Okay. And
So I guess. So what happens in in
QuestDB
is if you have a table like this
and you start sending
let's say, you, you know, you have a
sensor you're sending all your sensor data to
the same table. Right?
But not all your sensors are sending the
same values,
any missing value will just be filled with
a null.
Right?
So you'll have a table that is wider
with lots and lots of columns,
but a bunch of them are null depending
on what values are coming from what sensor.
Alright. Okay.
And,
every everything is on these eight byte boundaries,
so it's super fast to go
search through them.
Okay.
Interesting.
So I think
I'm definite my interest is peaked. I'm gonna
play with this more.
I won't pick up any more time today,
but I've been if you're happy to, and
I'll put you on the spot and ask
you here. But when the Grafana plug in
goes live, we'll do this again, and we'll
we'll have a play with that? Absolutely.
Yeah. And I'm I'm I am trust me.
I am, like, chomping at the bit to
get the Grafana plug in my hands on
the Grafana plug in. I'm gonna go poke
around in the and see if I can
actually grab it from
GitHub and and
build the the buggy version that's barely working
myself and make it work.
Alright.
Well,
thank you for joining me. I look forward
to our Grafana session, and enjoy your weekend.
I'll speak to you. I'll speak to again.
You too. It's great seeing you again. You
too, David. Bye. Bye.